nintendo has announced in a shareholder
meeting that their first mobile game me
tomo will launch on android and iOS
devices in japan in mid-march and in the
UK North America and Europe later that
month I'm Lisi and welcome to this
mobile game spot news update Nintendo
also revealed me photo a feature that
allows users to share images with others
via their favorite social networks
reregistration for me tomo will begin on
februari 17th and users can use the
Nintendo network ID Social Network
Accounts or email addresses to sign up
those that register will receive updates
about me tomo and get a special bonus
for the my nintendo rewards program
which is the replacement for club
nintendo although exact details still
haven't been provided about the mobile
game meter well kinda sounds similar to
Tomodachi life being billed as me tomo
is a social experience that uses
Nintendo's me characters to engage
friends in a light-hearted playful and
welcoming social setting using me
characters users will be able to
interact with their friends in an
entirely new way to spark fun and
interesting conversations such as what
song has been stuck in your head lately
do you believe in aliens and even if you
saw a nose hair sticking out of your
friends knows what would you do it
continues by answering questions in me
tomo users will be able to discover
surprising information and secrets about
their friends as well as share their
experiences with others easily by
talking and sharing photos featuring
their me using the me photo feature
Nintendo also clarified that me tomo
will be free to play with attractive
add-ons that people can pay for so are
you interested in Nintendo on mobile or
their new reward system let me know in
the comments box below I'll come find me
on Twitter I met Lucy James games for
all the latest on Nintendo make sure to
keep it gamespot